i filmed the beginnings of this journey
of fatherhood along that way it turned
into a career so something that was a
passion allowed me to take care of my
family doing something i really love i
just want you to stop eating random
things you find on the ground
my name is laguardia cross and i tell
the funniest parts of being a father
with my two daughters on youtube
mainly by making fun of myself
fatherhood came unexpectedly to me when
my wife called me in and let me know
that whoops a daisy we're about to have
a daughter
the beginning of me sharing my
experience as a father online was day
two of me being in the hospital i
described my first few days of being a
father and so when i did that the
response was like that's hilarious you
gotta share more about that and that was
the beginning of new father chronicles
nyelli's a year and a half
nageli is a determined baby
amala is three
she really really loves attention
[Music]
so whatever happens i usually would take
that and craft it into a story based
upon the funniest parts of it the very
first video that solidified new father
chronicles was interview with the
toddler so you've been alive for 14
months now you're walking you're talking
you're clapping you're dancing
you don't have to do an example it
allowed an open door to be able to
create a whole new kind of family
entertainment showcasing a very silly
but positive black family as the newest
and youngest member of the family from
your perspective who do you think is in
charge
oh you're so cute
and so confused
the thing that kind of really hit me to
let me know how important the work i was
doing was when i spoke to people about
it they were like let us just tell you
how important this work is and what it
means to us and to our families and in
the community overall and it just was a
motivating factor
there are not a whole lot of black
fathers on youtube doing what i'm doing
it is a blessing to me to be in this
space to be able to create the content
i'm making and so it's been incredible
to connect with other fathers online i'm
a cool dad i don't care what my girls
say
[Music]
you